[موسيقى]
والله في البدايه احنا في 2010 طبعا جت
مجموعه من الشباب الخيرين
لابن وليد وداروا دوره خاصه بصيانه المصحف
الشريف ونذكر فيها ذيك الدوره كانت تحمل
رقم 53 يعني مديرين 52 دوره قبل في
المناطق الاخرى وبعد ما خلط فيها المجموعه
هذه او في الدوره تدربت عليها يعني
وابنائي وتعلمنا عمليه الصيانه
وبعدها عجبتني فكره وفتحت مركز او مؤسسه
داخل منطقه بنهايه بالعمل هدايا
[موسيقى]
الله يبارك يعني خدماتكم طيبه ليل نهار
يقدم خدمات المدينه يقبل من المساجد من
البيوت يعني حتى يعابر سبيل الله يعني
يكونوا جالسين في المكتبه هنا بجنب المسجد
يعني
المركز الله يبارك يعني خدماتهم طيبه ولهم
سنين يقدمه يعني نسال الله ان يوفقهم
ويفتح عليهم يا رب العالمين
[موسيقى]